[♪♪♪]
JESSE: WELCOME TO "WATTERS'
WORLD."
I'M JESSE WATTERS.
THE DEMOCRATS' LOST CAUSE.
THAT'S THE SUBJECT OF TONIGHT'S
"WATTERS WORDS."
RONALD REAGAN WON TEXAS BY 30
POINTS, AND 40 YEARS LATER TRUMP
WON BY SINGLE DIGITS.
TRUMP BEAT BIDEN BY JUST 6
POINTS UNDER THESE LOOSE
PANDEMIC RULES.
DEMOCRATS WANTS TO MAKE THE
RULES PERMANENT.
TEXAS REPUBLICANS SAY NO.
WE WANT TO MAKE IT EASIER TO
VOTE, BUT HARDER TO CHEAT.
THE DEMOCRATS LEFT TEXAS LEAVING
THE LEGISLATURE HATCH EMPTY.
I -- HALF EMPTY.
I READ THE BILL SO YOU DON'T
HAVE TO.
AND MY BUDDY HAROLD FORD, JR.
COULDN'T POINTS OUT A SINGLE
THING THAT RESTRICTED VOTING.
THE RESTRICTIONS ARE YOU CAN'T
HAVE A POLLING STATION IN A
TENTS OR PARKING GARAGE.
SO NO POP-UP POLLING STATIONS.
WHEN YOU REQUEST A BALLOT BY
MAIL YOU HAVE TO REGISTER AND
WRITE YOUR I.D. THAT'S ON YOUR
LICENSE.
OR IF YOU DON'T HAVE A DRIERNLS
LICENSE, THE LAST FOUR NUMBERS
OF YOUR SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER.
HOW IS THAT RESTRICTIVE?
IT'S NOT.
COMPANIES ARE REQUIRED TO ALLOW
WORKERS TO LEAVE WORK ON
ELECTION DAY TO GO VOTE.
HERE IS WHAT MAKES IT HARDER TO
CHEAT IN TEXAS AND WHY THE
DEMOCRATS ARE HOWLING.
YOU CAN'T KICK POLL WATCHERS OUT
OF POLLING STATIONS.
AND THE POLL WORKERS NEED TO BE
ABLE TO SEE THE COUNT.
AND ALL VOTES HAVE TO HAVE A
PAPER TRAIL SO THEY CAN'T JUST
DISAPPEAR ON A MACHINE.
AND PAYING FOR VOTES BECOMES A
FELONY.
AND MACHINES HAVE TO HAVE
SOFTWARE THAT AREN'T ALLOWED TO
CHANGE VOTES.
AND OFFICIALS CAN'T JUST MAIL
OUT BALLOTS WITHOUT HAVING THEM
REQUESTED.
AND NO BALLOT HARVESTING.
TELL ME WHAT THE OBJECTION IS TO
THESE THINGS IN THE BILL?
ALL OF THE THINGS I JUST READ IS
ACTUALLY IN THE BILL.
WHAT IS OBJECTIONABLE.
COULDN'T ANSWER.
NOW THAT TRUMP IS GONE AND THE
PANDEMIC IS OVER.
THEY HAVE NOTHING.
THEY HAVE TO DEBATE THE POLICY
AND THEY CAN'T.
THEY ARE JUST LYING AND
SCREAMING RACISM.
BIDEN COULDN'T NAME A SINGLE
THING IN THE TEXAS BILL THAT
DISENFRANCHISES ANYBODY.
>> 21st CENTURY JIM CROW
ASSAULT IS REAL.
IT'S UNRELENTED.
WE'LL CHALLENGE IT VIGOROUSLY.
ARE YOU ON THE SIDE OF TRUTH OR
LIES, FACT OR FICTION.
JUSTICE OR INUS IS?
STAND UP, FOR GOD'S SAKE AND
HELP PREVENT THIS ASSERTED
EFFORT TO UNDERMINE OUR
ELECTIONS AND THE SACRED RIGHT
TO VOTE.
HAVE YOU NO SHAME?
WE ARE FACING THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT TEST OF OUR
DEMOCRACY SINCE THE CIVIL WAR.
JESSE: IF THIS WERE REALLY JIM
CROW, WHY ARE TEXAS DEMOCRATS
SMILING LIKE GOOCH BALLS WITH A
CASE OF BEER.
AND JIM CROW WAS A DEMOCRAT
OPERATION TO STOP BLACKS FROM
VOTING.
IT WAS REPUBLICANS WHO FREED THE
SLAVES.
KAMALA HARRIS EVEN COMPARED THE
TEXAS FLEE BAGGERS TO FREDERICK
DOUGLASS.
>> THEY TOOK ACTIONS IN LINE
WITH EVERYONE FROM FREDERICK
DOUGLASS WHEN HE FOUGHT FOR THE
RIGHT OF ABOUT BLACK MEN TO VOTE
IN AMERICA, TO THE LEGACY THAT
INCLUDES ALL THOSE WOMEN WHO
MARCHED DOWN PENNSYLVANIA
AVENUE.
FOR WOMEN'S RIGHT TO VOTE.
AND FOR ALL THOSE SHED THEIR
BLOOD ON THE BRIDGE TO MAKE SURE
WE PASS THE VOTING RIGHTS
ACT.
JESSE: THE DEMOCRATS HAVEN'T
RISKED.
THEY ARE ON A PRIVATE JET AND
POSTED SELFIES.
FREDERICK DOUGLASS WAS A GREAT
ORATOR.
BLACK PEOPLE DON'T HAVE SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBERS?
PLAQUE AMERICANS DON'T HAVE
I.D.?
HERE IS AMY HOROWITZ ASKED BLACK
VOTERS ABOUT THE VOTING LAWS.
>> DO YOU HAVE AN OPINION OF
VOTER I.D. LAWS?
>> THEY ARE PRETTY RACIST.
>> IT'S A WAY TO PERPETUATE RACE
I'M:THEY ARE LESS LIKELY TO HAVE
STATE I AM D.s.
SOME PEOPLE DON'T LIVE IN AREAS
WITH EASY ACCESS TO DMVs.
>> THEY DON'T HAVE THE KNOWLEDGE
OF HOW IT WORKS.
>> DO YOU HAVE I.D.?
>> YES, I DO.
>> DO YOU KNOW ANY BLACK PERSON
THAT DOESN'T CARRY I.D.?
>> EVERYONE I KNOW HAS I.D.
>> WE HEARD BLACK PEOPLE HAVE NO
ACCESS TO THE INTERNET.
>> EVERYBODY HAS ACCESS TO THE
INTERNET.
>> THEY ARE PRETTY MUCH
IGNORANT.
>> I THINK IT'S A LITTLE RACIST.
JESSE: THE ON PEOPLE WHO THINK
THESE LAWS ARE RACIST AND
SUPPRESS THE BLACK VOTE ARE
LIBERALS.
THEY WANT TO SCARE AME